Langsam ist es schon. Ein bisschen so als würden sich die indizien verdichten
Der mars rover curiosity hat erhebliche mengen organischen materials auf dem mars gefunden
Und inzwischen ist das ja einer von vielen kunden die. Leben früher oder sogar noch
Heute auf dem mars. Bedeuten könnten also was ist los auf dem mars klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ich muss jetzt doch noch, mal, eine dicke lanze für die whatsapp community brechen inzwischen. Kommen die themenvorschläge da am laufenden band rein
Und bevor ich ein thema finde hat sie
Irgendjemand aus der community bereits gefunden auf dem disco zwar sind alle unglaublich aktiv und es gibt jetzt sogar
eigene christoph images für jede stimmungslage
Ja vielen dank an christoph. Und slawistik und der absolute hammer heute erreichen wir
20.000 voller das ist eine der größten reichweiten auf wozzeck von einem youtuber und ich freue mich über. Jeden
Und jede die dabei ist wenn du das videos gibt es den link dazu es geht mit einem einfachen
Klick ja so was ist also auf dem maßlos wir hatten ja schon so die
Ein oder andere. Meldung wasser viel wasser wasser direkt unter der oberfläche
Einen fund der sehr verdächtig nach einem lebewesen oder in den spuren eines lebewesens aussah methan was hier auf der erde als
Indikator für leben gilt usw es gibt einfach immer mehr indizien für leben auf dem mars
Und jetzt das der mars rover curiosity der nasa hat auf der marsoberfläche
komplexe organische moleküle gefunden die gleichen kilo gehen dass hier auf der erde in erdöl und erdgas enthalten ist und
biologischen ursprungs ist
Und curiosity hat davon 100 mal
Mehr gefunden als bisher die forschungsgruppe vermutet, einen geologischen ursprung kann aber
Einen biologischen nicht ausschließen sie vermuten dass es nicht aus einem meteoriten stand womit die
Herkunft der mars wäre das wiederum nährt die hoffnung dass ist biologischen ursprungs sein könnte was wirklich krasses genau an dieser stelle
War vor milliarden. Jahren, ein see
Einen zuverlässigen nachweis ob das material biologischen oder biologischen ursprungs ist kann klose 10 nicht erbringen vielleicht ist das noch mal
Mehr anreiz möglichst bald weitere missionen zum mars. Zu schicken die proben auch wieder
zurück zur erde schicken können oder ihnen mars ist schneller ja das wird hochspannend
Erstmal ist jetzt exomars an die sonde der europäischen weltraumagentur esa wird sich in tiefen gesteinsschichten bohren
Und weitere erkennt sie bringen es bleibt. Also spannend auf dem mars wenn. Ihr kein video dazu
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt die youtuber box die
Funktioniert ja nicht dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst ihr kein video. Und über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir auch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Und zur begrüßung habe ich. Ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken. Und lasst uns sollte die
20.000 voll ohrmarke reisen ja und am besten auch how to music abonnieren das produzieren wir ja für funk
Und heute ist unser erstes musikvideo online gegangen. Also dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier dafür auch draufklicken da geht es. Um musik video und ich bin gespannt was haltet. Ihr davon
In swatch gerne die videos von auto musik. Bis dann
bleibt dran